I have two older brothers who both
attended military acmy and I think from
a very young age I saw a military
environment and thought it was super
super
cool my name is Nita q and I'm a current
senior in Yale College and I'm also a
Cadet in the Air Force RC program here
Veterans Day to me means a day not only
to thank our service members for what
they've done but also it's a day to
recognize the hardships in the sacri
ices that all service members face at
yel there have been many times where
I've needed a mentor or needed to ask
somebody a career question and there's
always someone who's gone through that
same struggle or had the same question I
realize that it's so inspiring to be a
part of something that's bigger than
yourself